Osama Arabi was just 14 when he was
arrested for the first time he was at a
protest when soldiers grabbed him that
was seven years ago it feels like
yesterday
we were protesting at a fur prison gate
the Army came and we escaped to the
mountain I ran for a long distance but
once they caught me they beat me with
their guns they stepped hard on my back
when they arrested me they kept beating
me beating beating beating then they
took me for interrogation
he was taken to a military prison there
he was beaten again verbally threatened
and refused access to a lawyer then he
was strip searched before being released
without charge
when they arrested me they stripped me
to search me I didn't understand what
they were searching for they didn't say
it was humiliating it made me very angry
It's Not Unusual here to see children
dragged Away by the army or police a new
report by the charity saved the children
says what is happening in the military
judicial system is a serious human
rights concern it reveals 42 percent of
the children arrested were injured
injuries included gunshot wounds and
broken bones 65 percent were arrested
during the night mostly between midnight
and Dawn 86 percent were beaten at some
point 76 percent threatened with
physical harm and 60 percent hit with
sticks or guns 69 were strip searched
boys made up 97 percent of the arrests
children are still being guilt
mistreated through the military
detention system they aren't these
safeguarding measures that you would
expect in place to keep children safe
now we're not saying children above the
law but there must be safeguarding
measures in place aligned to Global
Juvenile Justice standards to make sure
that children are safe Israeli law
doesn't apply in the West Bank but
Israel has signed International
agreements to protect children one
Israeli group says those treaties are
being ignored arrests should be the last
resort when there is no other
alternative and the arrest should be for
as short a period as possible and of
course children have to be protected
from violence from threats from other
abuse the report doesn't go into great
detail on the long-term impacts of these
arrests and the psychological damage it
can do to children for years to come
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Ramallah in the
occupied West Bank